hier sehen wir dass die steine wieder
eingesammelt werden sie wurden dann
scheinen von den demonstranten nicht
benutzt man hat sich bemüht hier ein
bisschen zur eskalation beizutragen aber
klappt halt nicht immer
[Musik]
10.000 verwirrte seelen hier in
frankfurt dabei weiß doch jeder wie gut
uns die ezb aber ruhig wer will nicht
mit gern verwechselt werden
wer sorgt sich um den frieden auf drum
in gassen wer kommt eure sinnlose augen
fällt nicht fassen will
wien
[Musik]
sind die frankfurter leider ja warum
lange dabei will nicht unsere stadt so
sehe wie sich jetzt momentan sich das so
entwickelt hier das ist ja schon eine
ausnahme zustand den man so gar nicht
mehr hinnehmen
diesen traurig traurig traurig aber die
am gespann frau
das ist nicht mehr unser fanden und das
nicht nur unsere frankfurt wie finden
sie das
beschissen warum sie nur gruppe wie so
vieles kaputt hauer
naja ist ja auch ein paar lange ich war
finde es unverschämt
also warum vergreife die sich am tote
gegenstände
das ist brutal und sich an tode
gegenständen für drei wurden gut also
hier unter dieser finanzpolitik und
unter den unter der ökonomischen kraft
der reichen leiden milliarden menschen
ja was ist ein brennender polizeiwagen
dagegen
hier sehen wir dass die steine wieder
eingesammelt werden sie wurden anschein
von den demonstranten nicht benutzt und
hat sich bemüht hier ein bisschen zur
eskalation beizutragen aber klappt halt
nicht immer
schöne stadt kapitalismus
ach so
[Musik]
betragen
b
mein name ist mit börsenkorrespondent
die an der frankfurter börse
sie sind so zur arbeit gegangen ja ich
bin so zur arbeit gegangen da bin ich
patriot ist genug glocke kann sich
ansehen wie sie will ob mit oder ohne
maske lebensmüde
wir gehen vielleicht einen guten rat an
gerade junge leute börse ist die
vergangenheit börse ist immer zukunft
das heißt es wird in zukunft gekauft was
braucht der mensch
er will gesund bleiben er will fit
bleiben also alles was mit pharma zu tun
hat mit healthcare wird laufen aber eine
frage hätte dann natürlich noch wo sind
die asoziale elemente zu finden draußen
bei den demos oder hier unten auf dem
parkett
da will ich ganz klar sagen die banker
getroffen die frauen sie heute wieder
auf die straße
ich weiß nicht vielleicht war das auch
hologrammen wir die 100 technisch schon
ziemlich weiter ist kantons nicht genau
einschätzen
im zu drogen das auch regelmäßig habe
das geht auch nur wesentlich wichtigen
zinsen durch die ezb also darauf
geholfen
du gehörst auf durch protest ist aber so
eigentlich auch schon mal über deine
altersvorsorge nachgedacht
das ist eine frage wird es mit gerade
branchen da wir sie fragen wie sehr sie
finden blödsinn
warum wollten sich doch die leute an die
hier demonstrieren haben kein geld
wahrscheinlich gehabt
[Musik]
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße